so yesterday
we were i think michael we were talking
to stroke we're talking to tom haberstro
and he was talking about um we're
talking about lebron and anthony davis
extending lebron's prime and
we got into a conversation about what
lebron could do
to pass jordan as the goat and stroll
was saying maybe passing kareem at all
times scoreless would help blah blah
blah remember that conversation then i
get a text
which i love these texts vinnie goodwill
is like
there's nothing lebron can do to win the
goat debate all right vinny
the floor is yours i mean
seriously guys the only way that he can
win the goat debate
is by becoming a better basketball
player and he's not going to become a
better basketball player
at this advanced stage of his career and
that's no shock
and that's no shade to lebron james
because what he's doing at his age at
this stage of his career
is phenomenal but here's the important
thing about this guys
we don't need the numbers to show you
that michael jordan is a better
basketball player and
let me be clear here guys i'm in detroit
i'm a detroit native i am least inclined
to take to say to anybody
walking the face of earth that michael
jordan is the greatest basketball player
of all time
right i've never got a dog in this fight
no dog in the fight whatsoever i worked
in chicago and chicago hated me
because i cracked on them all the time
about how the pistons cracked the bull's
head
so before people come in my mentions
will come to y'all saying you know
you're a jordan
homer or whatever lebron hater i'm
speaking completely
objectively from here here's two things
that that strike out to me
as lebron and michael the league and the
game are two different things right the
league is what the
teams look like and who you're playing
against and everything else the game
is about the rules and the way and the
style and everything else right
the league was made for michael jordan
because there was no peer for him
but the game was not the game was a big
man's game
the game was made for elijah wanted
david robinson and patrick ewing and
kareem abdul-jabbar
and he was a wing player barely 200
pounds
dominating the game the way that he did
when he became a franchise in himself
right
lebron has the game made for him because
you get the floor spread you got nothing
but shooters
you got high usage you got the measuring
of usage where we know that efficiency
being something in a way that it did not
mean something in the 90s when michael
jordan played once something becomes a
measurable guys
it gives the advantage to someone in the
in terms of evolution
you know what i'm saying because three
means more than two but the three-point
shot was not emphasized back then
you think michael jordan would not have
become a better three-point shooter
and finally this is the biggest thing to
me guys
we talked about system michael jordan
played in a system
that was geared toward enhancing
everybody else it was geared toward
making the bj
armstrongs the john paxton's the scottie
pippins the bill cartwrights
it was geared toward making them their
best selves
it was not guaranteed michael jordan
right it was not geared toward mako
making michael jordan the best
statistical version of himself he had to
retrofit his game
to fit inside the triangle and then you
built the team around
you know that system with lebron lebron
is the system
you build your team around his talents
around what makes him
feel best you know longer and better
than everybody else
michael thrived in spite of the triangle
offense
when you think about michael jordan the
michael jordan that we initially grew up
watching when michael was
art and driving to the basket and
everything else the triangle compresses
that
it doesn't make you be the best version
of yourself if you're an extreme athlete
it turns you into a jump shooter and
what did michael jordan do
he made himself into the best mid-range
shooter that we've ever seen
he had no structural flaws in his game
we've seen lebron with flaws in his game
we saw jimmy butler expose it in game
five when he took
and forced lebron to go all the way to
his right in that last play
and he had to kick it to danny green you
can't crowd michael jordan that way
in his early prime or late prime there
were holes
that lebron has that can be exploited
that cannot be exploited with michael
jordan and it has nothing to do with
you know wanting my guy to be this or
wanting somebody else's guy to be that
those are empirical facts that we talk
about when evaluating the game of
basketball
and i'm interested with you guys and
having a good
faith discussion that has nothing to do
with narratives and nothing to do with
man i want to be able to say that lebron
is my guy and i witnessed the greatest
basketball player to ever live
i don't care about any of that i've seen
lebron in person way more than i've seen
michael jordan in person
but what i'm going to objectively tell
you is that maybe that's part of the
problem
that might be part of the
just want problem point out something i
just wanna say so
before you go back i just wanna i'm
crying i'm crying tears of joy
i'm so proud of you right now though i'm
so proud of you though like
that i mean listen this was your
definitive moment
you have had a great career without and
you you
you do work vinnie i have heard and seen
you do work
you have never ever laid down you laid
your game down quite
flat just now that's how you drive from
now on
that's how you drive okay like that's
incredible
okay michael go ahead have that i'm just
proud of my guy right now go ahead mike
no i'm proud of him i'm proud of him too
i thought it was a ring
it was a great presentation
you know the great debaters denzel wants
you on the team
it was really well done um but i'm going
to say
part maybe part of the problem is that
you have seen lebron
more than you've seen jordan in person
and so maybe you start to pick
a pick apart some of the flaws from
seeing them up close whereas jordan
the myth of jordan the legend of jordan
from afar
might be skewing your view a little bit
but beyond that
okay you talk about the triangle offense
and how he had to retrofit his game
vinnie still a 10 time scoring champ so
before the triangle
that ada season what he averaged 35
and then under phil you got to take it
down to 31.32
at offense vinnie is still built around
michael jordan
and it's not like he he took something
away
maybe the triangle added some things to
his games look at the assist numbers
maybe the rebounding numbers michael
jordan at times in the triangle
was there was a point guard because he
never really had a traditional
point guard who was setting him up so
i i don't know i know not about that
argument not quite because michael's
best statistical season from
rebounds and assists was in 89 when he
averaged 32 8-8
and that was with doug collins as his
head coach and not phil jackson phil
jackson came in
the next season i think we've turned
michael jordan honestly into
a bit of this one-dimensional score who
couldn't do anything
else by comparison triple doubles
when michael jordan a great distributor
michael jordan was one of the few
players maybe the only player
in nba history to get 200 steals 100
blocks in the same season
when mvp and defensive player of the
year i think elijah
and giannis were the other two players
and giannis came up short in the
playoffs that
this year when he got that so i think
honestly we've undersold
michael jordan because we've seen lebron
james i think the lebron legions
as opposed to lebron's game lifting him
above jordan they try to suppress
michael's greatness as opposed to
looking at michael's accomplishments or
lebron's accomplishments and saying that
he's better
the thing is we know he's not
better you can be bigger faster stronger
that does not make you a
better basketball player especially
here's the other thing about it holly
michael jordan has this great talent of
scottie pippen you know what your best
self be your best self
dennis rodman be your best self when
you're lebron james
star players up until this point become
role players
because you have to suppress yourself to
make lebron
his best self dwyane wade had to
suppress his game kevin love
chris bosh all of these guys who have
played with him
and have been generational talents in
their own right have had to sort of
retrofit their games and not be their
best self
around lebron scotty pippin was his best
self times two
playing next to michael jordan because
why because michael jordan's greatness
had nothing to do with
you michael was going to be great no
matter who he played with
who he played against the system the
rules no matter what
these are a special set of circumstances
that require lebron to be lebron now
don't get me wrong
he may be the second or third greatest
player of all time
but we cannot act as if these things
happen turning star players into role
players
is something that magic johnson didn't
do it's something that larry bird didn't
do
it's something that michael jordan
didn't do you could be your best self
playing next to those guys with lebron
you have to converge your talents
suppress your talents and your greatness
so that he can be great
first and foremost yo man
i'm like i'm like smoking friday right
now that's my dog
that's my dog like say bro
we got a man michael we got to start
paying vinnie goodwill
i agree you guys are paying benny like
you can't keep giving
if you're good at something never do it
for free vinnie can't keep showing up
laying down facts like this for free
pity
just now that was incred go ahead mike
i'm sorry i'm just i'm gonna let you
know what's gonna tell you
guys i agree that's the one thing we
that's a unanimous agreement
that vinnie goodwill needs to be paid
now i can't give him unanimous agreement
on this
star players become role players like
dwayne wade had to change
dwyane wade had to change his game
because lebron james was better
but not like dwyane wade was still
holding it down i mean they went to four
straight finals
it wasn't because hey lebron was up here
and everybody else was
was spectating dwyane wade had to take a
step back because they virtually
averaged the same thing in that first
year
dwyane wade had no problem playing with
lebron you saw in that 2011 finals if
the heat win
the wayne wade is the mvp if lebron puts
together a
milk toast nba finals dwayne white does
more
than enough to win mvp and here's my
other thing guys
since win has a number equal
okay i'm the greatest we knew michael
jordan was the greatest in 1993
and he won three championships we didn't
say oh this third championship puts him
up there with larry bird but two behind
magic johnson
and when he won his sixth title in 1998
we didn't say man this puts him right
there with kareem
and right above magic no we knew that he
was the greatest we'd ever seen because
we had eyes and we didn't need
the number crowd to tell us well now
that he's reached his fourth
championship
now he's the greatest no no no and he
didn't have to sell himself that's the
one thing about this
is that lebron is like one of these guys
that's like you know i don't care about
how i look
i don't care about you know y'all i
don't care if y'all like my shoes or not
i like my shoes though that's that's my
point
he needs that constant validation
mike i'm gonna tell you this y'all
setting the audience up we talk it's not
just us here so remember the scene
where eddie murphy had just met
jacqueline played by robin gibbons and
they were exercising and he was talking
about you know i'd wait on her she fine
and martin lawman says you know what if
a woman that find our way eight or nine
months
and they don't have them greater than
eight or nine years
lebron will play another 89 years at
this level still not be better than
michael jordan because it's not about
longevity to me
it's about how good are you when you are
at
your best and the best of lebron which
might have been what 2012
13 you know in that in that range the as
a defensive player as a complete player
as an outside shooter everything else as
an athlete
is still not a better player than the
best of michael jordan so he can do all
these things
now and still not be better then
i i this is don't take this i feel like
i'm just i need to just pass the torch
or no better yet we on the roof we on
the roof after the bishop just fell
look hey man you got the juice now you
gotta juice
i mean like bro i'm like i am so proud
of you
like i i can't tell but i feel like i'm
listening to myself except better
because i can't tell you how many times
i've been trying to tell these people to
stop underrating michael jordan's
all-around game
i can't tell you how many times i keep
telling these people
to stop acting like some kind of eight
championships
will will make him better than michael
jordan because his team wins eight
championships and conversely
i don't hold lebron's championship
losses against him because it's a team
accomplishment for the most part
so look man i am just so
proud and thankful for what you did i'm
gonna make sure that we clip this off
i'm gonna give it to you like keep it
i'ma cherish this moment
i will cherish this experience for the
rest of my life
because i'm telling you you just
literally
like it just i'm so i could i could not
have said it better myself but i feel
like i'm pretty good at this job i could
not have said it better myself
i'm gonna set you all up on another
topic though because i know
you're detroit guy michael your favorite
artist of all time
yeah yes let's hear it michael you go
first yeah i mean stevie wonder
man i don't even know that was the thing
michael holly
yeah vinnie i i got to hear your take on
it like stevie
stevie i mean stevie we had little
stevie wonder we got stevie
stevie through the 70s and like stevie
in motown
vinnie look man there's some there's
some
memories that i just will i'll never
forget man i remember
my grandmother's house remember those
old they called them floor models
where you had like an eight-track you
had an eight-track in one part
then the other yeah it's playing 45s and
used to open the cabinet and she had all
these 45s in there you see the motown
logo on there and stevie wonder i mean
that just that's my
childhood that's my adulthood the ghost
how do you feel about this
it's it feels like the fat boy is
breaking up to be perfectly honest
stevie leaving motown feels like the fat
boy is breaking up if you are a child of
detroit
then motown museum is a part of your
life that motown music
is basically the soundtrack to your
childhood i've gone to motown museum and
seen
everything from the temptations to the
supremes to even the people who were on
motown and didn't necessarily make an
imprint like the eisley brothers
you know what i think like there are so
many different people that but stevie
is the crown jewel like you can name
your favorite stevie
album and five people can come up with
five different answers he's the voice of
our generation
i will not go on this stevie blind thing
you know what i'm saying but i will say
the greatest concert i've ever been to
in my life was the songs in the kid life
concert i nearly skipped the game as a
beat writer in 2014.
if you don't have a flight to go to
atlanta because i needed to go see
stevie wonder that's like seeing eddie
murphy
doing stand-up that's like doing the
seeing the best
of the best is stevie it's prince it's
aretha
and then it's like everybody else after
that
yeah even the headline got me like
stevie leaves motown to form his own
label it's like
mohawk might as well be his own label i
mean it's like this is synonymous
with each other you know what i mean
it's like we need some investigative
reporting on this
we need an investigative report what
happened don't we mike don't you want to
know what happens
after 60 years after 60 years what
happened
now after 60 years that didn't happen
at 55 or 50. it's like why now you know
it's
this is mind-blowing it doesn't make
sense right and
you know what ever since motown moved
out to la and they left detroit
they lost marvin gaye they lost you know
the jackson five we had to turn the
jackson five into the jackson
five you know what i'm saying they
changed the name
and everything else so no if motown
comes back to detroit
we can be back we can be the center of
music again we can make music great
again
wait i don't i can't believe i'm saying
oh don't do that don't do that
yo yo before i'm sorry michael yeah
something else i was gonna say one more
thing before we let him go yeah
i'm just gonna affirm that that we agree
that song's in the key of life tour
i saw that uh in boston same year
it was great i'm aware as a matter of
fact vinnie next time you come on i'm
gonna wear the t-shirt still had a
t-shirt
six years old uh from that concert it's
a little faded
and i'll tell you a story i got tickets
and my wife
my wife said oh yeah oh you got tickets
i got some book club event tonight i
said
you're going to go to a book club event
stevie i'm still married but this is
going to marry
because this is what she said to me
vinnie she said to me
oh it's too bad you're going to miss the
concert i said oh no no no no
oh no no oh i see stevie by myself
which i did great concert like stephen
to see
stevie in concert
to me that's the greatest song ever
written it's an experience and i know
there's a lot of songs and everything
else
but as from songs in the key of life to
me is the greatest song
ever written and performed by a human
being and that came out 10 years before
i was born
no no argue no argument there yo i
cannot let you get up out of here
uh without giving us some knowledge on
this these giannis stories
i know windhorst said it um a lot of a
lot of people been writing about
the mavericks like everybody else you
know wanting to pursue giannis and
tentacomo if he passes up the super max
in milwaukee and decides he wants to
take his talents elsewhere
apparently you know they got uh they got
some front office connections whether
it's donnie nelson or whoever they feel
like they got an inside track
on attracting him to playing alongside
uh luca which is scary but feels a
little
feels a little crowded but whatever yes
yeah yeah redundant there's the word
that's yeah that's what i was trying to
get at um
what do you see in giannis future man
first of all is he leaving and if so
is dallas really uh one of the leading
suitors for his services
i don't know if he's leaving i don't
know if dallas is going to be the place
that he would necessarily
go you know playing with porzingis and
and luca it sounds nice but i don't know
i think that might be too much on the
plate the two teams that i heard up
when i was in when [ __ ] when the bubble
was going on the two teams that i heard
were the two teams at the top of your
list miami and toronto
now with the way miami put out and we
know about heat culture and we know
about
the way that pat riley likes to go after
their stars
i love to see that beach like you can
you can add him to jimmy butler
and the way that jimmy played and add
another top guy next time and it doesn't
feel crowded
it just feels like they got to figure
out who's in charge and we know who's
going to be in charge and in toronto
toronto has the international flavor
with messiah you jerry
in their long-standing relationship so i
would not be surprised if messiah
goes big game hunting again look he took
a chance on getting kawhi leonard and he
gave up
mother rose and to do it do you think
that he would not do anything less
to try to get giannis antonio cumpo in
toronto take the chance on the
relationship
and go from there i think dallas is like
that to me dallas goes after every big
free agent right
and they still haven't gotten one
remember they were supposedly
in the lebron sweepstakes in 2010 they
were supposedly in the dwight power
sweepstakes
in 2014 and all these other different
things and they never seen
the clippers that guy yeah yeah
yeah him too yeah yeah all all of them
and i and i think they have a good
organization a great head coach
but i don't know if giannis would sign
up necessarily to play with that
team i think he was that's what it is
deandre jordan yeah yeah
neither one of us would like my man from
the clippers either one of us
like uh your boy your boy yeah yeah
but i don't i don't think there's any i
don't think they're
ahead of toronto or miami if it comes
down to it
yo dog um next time you got that
that that many hot takes next time
you're going to spit high fire like that
let me know and i'll just take the day
off
you could be you could be one brother
all right time dawg
it's cherry come over anytime do the
solo brother come on and just take it
just take it okay i can't do the whole i
can't do the whole thing i gotta do one
of y'all
that's why i might go what is that for
you today
let me see it i can't see it let's see
let's see
that's dude all right i see you martin i
see you
appreciate you guys i'm in detroit all
that stuff so i figured y'all like it
love you bro thank you